[Music]
foreign there you are watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the observer's
chief leader writer Sonia soda and the
former conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle welcome to both of you so front
pages then let us start with the Metro
describing Prince Harry as having been
given a reality check during his high
court testimony with the mirror groups
lawyer insisting his claims of phone
hacking are in the realm of speculation
The Daily Mail offers an analysis from
their columnist John Moyer who has
little sympathy for Harry
the financial times quotes the Ukrainian
president valora mizalenski saying
Russia has detonated a bomb of mass
environmental damage after the breach of
a major Dam on the danipro river
the eye calls the incident a war crime
and says 40 000 people have been
displaced and the situation in Ukraine
is also the main concern for the
guardian
away from Ukraine The Daily Mirror leads
with calls from Rob Burr's wife tonight
his former teammate and fundraiser Kevin
sinfield
the express has word of a supposedly
game-changing weight loss drug
and the star queries the low rate of
convictions for burglaries across the
country
a quick reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see it on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages for yourself while you watch us so
let's head straight to Our Guest then
Sonia soda and Salma Shaw welcome to
both of you
um some extraordinary pictures today uh
Sonia including the guardian at
environmental disaster you know a
hundred villages flooded this major city
of Hassan real implications for both the
war the economy and the livelihoods of
people in southern Ukraine
that's right so this Dam that's been
destroyed is an absolutely huge Dam it's
two kilometers long much much bigger in
scale than anything we've got here in
the UK many times more bigger and Richie
sunak the Prime Minister has just issued
a comment tonight in which he calls this
you know the biggest attack on Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure it's really hard
to overstate
um the scale of the damage that this
will cause uh you know the human damage
um to many many ukrainians but also the
vast environmental damage this is going
to have huge repercussions and there may
be lots of knock-on effects um so this
obviously affects water supply it
actually affects uh potentially
um the cooling of a massive nuclear
power station in Ukraine
um although thankfully experts say that
there is a there are enough safety
measures in place that um it shouldn't
be affected for many weeks to come or
being well but this is absolutely
massive in scale and it comes just as um
you know this talk of Ukraine launching
a counter-offensive against Russian
forces in Ukraine trying to capture uh
back lost grounds this this summer uh
ground that has been uh taken over by
Russian forces so it's a really really
significant event um uh in the war
yes and the Prime Minister on his way to
Washington you know somewhat equivocal
at this stage about who is to blame
um Salma uh he says our military and
intelligence agencies are currently
looking at it too soon to preempt that
and make a definitive judgment but what
I can say is if it's intentional it
would represent I think a Sonia quoted
the largest attack on civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine since the
start of the war and just demonstrates
the new lows that we would have seen
from Russian aggression he went on to
say attacks on civilian infrastructure
are appalling and wrong
um similar from the uh the White House
discussions at the U.N security agency
but this is hugely significant is it not
and long feared that's the point about
this
oh yeah of course it's hugely
significant and of course of course
there is also a difference in the way
that people are being quoted so as you
say the Prime Minister has had some
Nuance in his statement the Russians
have strongly denied that they're
responsible for this and as uh for as
their form goes uh suggesting that is
it's an act of self-sabotage by Ukraine
um and the president of the European
Council has called it and is quoted as
calling it a war crime um ukrainians are
calling it an act of Terror so there is
there is some Nuance because of course
it then becomes incumbent on uh Western
Powers uh to then consider what their
response is going to be to this and as
Sonia's just spoken about
um this also will create some issue for
the war effort on on Ukraine's part
because this is a huge uh catastrophe
which is going to require a lot of
resource from the Army and of course the
government's attention because we are
talking about forty thousand people who
are going to be displaced as a
consequence of this not just the
environmental catastrophe but what this
does to surrounding infrastructure and
and we actually this is the first part
of it we don't actually know how this is
going to play out in terms of the
flooding
yes and that 40 000 is the figure we can
see there on the front page of the eye
uh Selma at least 150 tons of oil from
the dam has already leaked into the
danipro river that's cut into the
environment Minister for Ukraine it's
the dam itself one of the biggest in the
world and certainly the other comments
from Rishi sunak is about you know their
first response has to be humanitarian uh
trying to help all those people who are
fleeing
um or being moved I mean is Russia
moving them to Russia Sonia
well I mean I think that's the question
because
um initially it looks like this is going
to have a much bigger impact in terms of
the destruction destruction of Russian
um controlled areas of Ukraine so what's
going to happen to those um Ukrainian uh
citizens
um I think this and what kind of
humanitarian efforts are going to be
supplied to them in in areas that are
controlled by Russia I think that's a
really big question I think it's
important to say as well although you
know some people are being quite
cautious before we know too much more
about attributing blame to Russia
although interestingly I think the EU
has already done that a sort of one
delay and has gone so far as to do that
I think it's important to say that one
thing we do know is that this dam was
controlled by Russia in the run-up to
this um huge explosion and one thing the
ukrainians are saying is this scale of
damage it cannot have been caused by an
attack on the dam sort of uh from the
outside uh it looks like an attack that
that has happened you know from the dam
itself yeah and certainly residents were
suggesting that her son is the garden of
Ukraine I see that wheat prices have
already surged uh one figure of 2.4
another coating three percent has big
implications therefore for you know
feeding other parts of the world so
everyone will be watching closely
because this is ongoing it is still
actively flooding and we'll certainly
keep an eye on that uh in the meantime
the other big story um Salma front page
of the metro and a number of other
newspapers uh Prince Harry um they call
it his reality check cross-examined not
the Cozy interviews possibly he's seen
before
no indeed and of course this is one of
the great preoccupations of the
newspapers tomorrow because it deals
directly with uh what Prince Harry has
said is uh the practice of newspapers or
certainly was when he was growing up so
there's been some quite emotional
testimony from Prince Harry uh in court
today and as we go through the papers
we'll see a different sort of a
perspective on that
um I mean nobody can sort of deny that
this person has had a very difficult
time and when you go through that
testimony and he talks about you know
not being able to trust people uh
because of these stories appearing
um you know it's it nobody can sort of
prevent themselves from being slightly
sympathetic if not more so towards him
but the Crux of the issue is about his
allegations around the legality of how
that information was obtained and that
is the contentious piece that is
unfolding in the courtroom at the moment
yes suggestions of you might have been
filmed going into a pub because or a
restaurant is that a celebrity chef
there it wasn't necessarily something
that been leaked suggestions that it
might have been in the paper before
that's why mirror journalists were there
you know you could see the pattern of
Defense from the mirror um Sonia during
today's testimony
you can and I think there's going to be
a lot of sympathy for Harry and what he
speaks about
um and what we've spoken about in court
today
um but the issue is that you know the
the the weight is on him he's the person
who has to prove his allegations about
the mirror we know that the Mirror Has
acknowledged and admitted to hacking the
phones of many people in order to get
stories
um but in this case Harry has to prove
that in relation to the stories that
he's putting forwards those stories were
obtained by the mirror through unlawful
means and that's quite a tough bar to
that's quite a tough threshold to cross
in a court of law and that's why we're
seeing the pushback from the mirrors uh
lawyers where the KC uh cross-examining
Harry is sort of putting a lot of
pressure on him and saying well this
this story that was already reported in
the press that you've put forward
couldn't this detail have come from here
so what the mirrors lawyers are trying
going to do is sort of say to the judge
well there's no proof here that this
came that this information was was
obtained to unlawful means so it is
quite a high bar that Harry has to clear
however I do think that for you know for
Prince Harry he's been very clear that
he's you know he's going to do what he
can to expose
um the part that he feels the Tabloid
press has paid in you know making his
life very difficult and uh the life of
his wife Megan uh uh Duchess of
um uh Sussex very difficult as well and
so you know perhaps for him obviously he
wants to try and prove this in court but
even this getting an airing in court uh
Mike for him you know be part of his
objectives yes and the guardian
um you know using the word vile Prince
Harry said vile British tabloids had a
devastating impact on his mental health
but there were broader attacks too uh
weren't there Salma on the state of the
British press and the government as both
being at rock bottom with the government
having no appetite for for press
regulation
um some commentators suggesting this is
an establishment figure attacking the
establishment
well it's interesting because he sort of
calls out uh the prime minister in his
uh in his testimony uh and he's is
insinuating that there's too much
closeness between uh the the press and
government and I think that to some
extent he's there's a slight naive
perspective because of course you know
journalists hold a government to account
and having been someone on the inside of
government and you know Sonia too
journalists do hold governments to
account they do hold Prime Ministers to
account so I think that some of that is
actually slightly misplaced although you
know he's now no longer a working member
of the royal family and he's perfectly
entitled to have his view on this but it
is just a view
daily mail
um Jan Moyer uh he must have longed for
the schmozzy Embrace of Oprah at last
here we go curtain up drum roll lights
action Here Comes The Judge closely
followed by the Duke of Sussex one day
late
um Etc
um different papers with different views
presumably depending on whether or not
they are subject to this kind of action
from Prince Harry's Sonia
yeah I think that's right I think you
can see um a division in the Press I
think the Daily Mail front page it's
obviously this column by Jan Moyer is
referencing the fact that uh being
cross-examined in court is no walk in
the park and it's very different to
doing a celebrity interview like being
interviewed by Oprah Winfrey for example
however I'm sure Prince Harry was aware
of that before he gave um evidence in
this trial and he he made the decision
that he was going to do it anyway I'm
sure he'll be very clear about the risks
um that there are um involved for him
and anybody who's watched any form of
trial um you know this is a high profile
trial in the high court knows that you
come under quite intense scrutiny from
um barristers from the other side so I'm
sure Harry himself would have done a lot
of preparation with his advisors um for
this moment and I think the fact that
he's come in for some quite Fierce
cross-examination that's not a surprise
that's exactly what you'd expect in a
high profile trial um uh in in the high
court